hello there reject nation thank you guys so much
for clicking on this video we have made it to the
umbrella academy season three finale yeah
this last half has been awesome it has just
been getting progressively more awesome
and engaging and shocking and revelatory
but loving it i've been loving it if you have if
you're just having a click on here not watching
or once just started like episode five or six man
i feel like there's like some really good
stuff in the first half but they're great stuff
has been like pretty solid from the in
the last half yeah guys uh leave a like
uh that helps sign the algorithm and subscribe
and click the notification bell in case something
else pops up on this channel that you're like
yeah i want to check that out and full length
watch alongs where you sync up with the time code
are available for our super sexy rejects over at
our patreon page thank you all who have joined
for umbrella academy thus far we cover a bunch
of shows over there as well where some shows have
exclusive reaction highlights included and uh the
team of prepper thank you guys for helping us edit
down these highlights and thank you aaron again
for joining me on this journey now you're the only
one i know that in in real life watches umbrella
academy so no one else would rather watch it with
and uh yeah guys let's see what ends up happening
in this episode i can't wait to find out hopefully
it sticks the landing all right let's get to it
i lost the other side where's klaus children
i'm sorry but your brother i did all i could
but it didn't make it through in in time the
best minds of the age theorize we live in a
clockwork cosmos in the quantum age time
and space are suspected to be a holograph
ancient people what makes you feel tiny
huh why would you put pineapple on a pizza
we are just tiny specks of sand true where exactly
are we i'm dead man we're dead welcome to my hood
welcome to my hood oh where's
the umbrella it was on the flag
ah i caught it nice i looked for
it now that people braided us
covered our asses nice does anyone know what
that sign says yeah it says do not ring the bell
what do we do does anybody
know reggie reggie sweden
calling her dad by his first name oh my gosh
dad killed me oh my god he killed me too a lot
he's an alien we're trying not to use that kind
of terminology here you could just say he's
british all my life i've been a loser i've been
a freak i've made mistake after mistake after
mistake it was a sign that this is my home it's
where i meant to be this shitty place we're dead
right as the duggy baby that's the
dougie so what happens if i do this
nice try big guy but there ain't no
pain in the boy yeah take your best shot
like how this that looks like a 1950 set i can see
it i don't get it like we're with the people that
loved us the most okay so why wouldn't we tell
them things suck right now and it would be nice to
give the family something to fight for you shut up
and eat your fish are you lying again no she's not
okay she's just scared she doesn't want to be
seen as weak are you really sure that he could
kill luther i think he could kill luther klaus
and the rest of us without breaking a moral sweat
and what's worse i think allison is involved no
no god i love you five always the smartest look
even if you're right i can't imagine they're
just gonna come clean if we confront them
i agree i like how his
voice has been coming deeper
victor relax don't worry you have all the time
in the world to get over it all right that's it
what the hell
oh this is someone's idea of heaven
hey buddy
this is fun
we're gonna see you open up now he's
still thinking about that bachelor party
still getting invited we're here now in the hotel
oblivion just like you wanted i made that happen
don't be ridiculous allison killed harlan and i
united the families what did you do number two
the bells are just a metaphor for this
sergio correct number five um great so we'll
just stay in the hotel forever staring at the
walls and eating bad sushi finding the sigil is
our only way out of here and the best chance we
have of resetting the universe funny how
you and dad are on the same page again
i forgot my journey go on i'll meet you on fire
what's your plan come on summon the guardian
you know your deal is costing people their lives
do you really think that i made a deal
with a dad to kill luther and klaus
i'm done i mean ugh that part of her
story is true she did not technically
just listen to me
trying to be defensive to
cover your ass oh this is five
whoa victor allison what is this place you're the
ones who said to hell with family and
the whole universe i'm the only one
fighting to save both we just need to know what
dad is planning before more of us get killed
where the hell is five he was right
behind me it's just so mysterious
little fun house what's going on
three who's number three i don't know
why tell the truth when you can just mind [__]
someone into getting what you want without ever
having to be truly vulnerable do you know how
crazy that is what if i fail i'll baby like
my mum found me mom is behind that crazy [__]
he's a good and decent person usually one
come on just gonna leave that in the ceiling he
was never a sparrow he was our dad and a shitty
one at that you don't need him easy for you to
say when you've already got a new family the
best part of that family just died can't believe
i'm saying this i'm actually glad to see you guys
oh problem dad you he missed me wow i wish i
could explore this more my boy but now isn't
a good time you used me you know to get
the family unless he's tripping you used
me and then when i was no more used to you just
leave me to die on the floor leave you to die
i did you a favor i knew you'd find your way back
to the void where you belong i do like it there
those dollar stores which
are quite freeze that's that
what the hell is happening we
should get back to the lobby
yeah which one of our moronic siblings
do you think rang the damn bell
who did it
there's multiple like ancient asian warriors right
nice
nice show sweetie
you didn't do much homie oh [__] me
go go go go go go go go go press a button okay
whoa what floor oh [__] anyone oh i'm so scared
oh okay revenge looks good on her would
you shut up and help us kill this thing
oh he's got an axe again the deadliest
one of them all okay just stand there
that's cool too did this for all of us
lutheran class too what did he have for you
i need you to trust me look at me if we
get through this everything's gonna be okay
what the hell is the deal
right just say it already
oh [__] oh you're separated you're
screwed you're screwed dude allison
victor there's got to be some way to navigate this
i'm gonna guess has something
to do with the numbers hey
hey what do you think you're doing
i'm protecting my family all right
you promised we'd always be together i know i
know well what a hell of a shot the armor it's
like hitting somebody there's a space between
the bracket plates you need to get behind me
let's kill this thing wait sloan
oh god
damn
goddamn ben finally
oh there it is oh the seven
oh [__] the seed jewel
we did it we completed the entire mission
finally someone with a power worth mimicking
lila some weird adr right i'll explain later
from the trailer and the thumbnail on netflix
oh yeah it's pretty cool
let's see what's happening
at least this time we're not aiming at each other
nice oh wow you put a dent in that thing
a little bit more than that just do that
to every one of them guys never separate
claps
i'm still confused about how klaus got
there because doesn't he need to a body to
just roll with it right now all right
question later oh we look like hell oh
you tried killing the guardian we just did
so did we i told you to stay in the beach
that's toxic love for you i love you
you brought us here to die that's not
so somewhere in this hotel is the key
to resetting the universe we just need to
find the city i don't care about your sigil
none of us do no we barely survived that
guardian with a stupid helmet and a sickle
are they standing on it x marks the spot who's
on the back of the warrior there's one left
i have to go after it because that worked so
well the first time no they're standing on it
hey i found the sigil
oh
not five that's how he becomes
old five he lost it it's official
it'll be fine
[__] [__] [__]
what
what the hell gross it's all spongy huh
yeah that's gross i left you to god the
most precious thing in the universe
and what was it you'll soon understand
you all will i have a feeling
we're not going to learn
yeah he's a ghost oh no
he just animated him no klaus i can't hold it
i will love you forever oh man oh wow
oh if i was slow and i'd murder
that horror graves right now
he'll be
that's so back the devil is in the lobby floor
it's the stars seven points seven of us no not you
what the [__] is going on it's the
only way to stop him oh [__] oh [__]
what is happening
why do you say not allison
fascinating what is happening
what is going on holy crap what is happening
what
this is wild particles inside their bodies
are the only things that fuel the machine
clouds he won't stop until we're all dead
god damn it allison
oh it's exposed did you see that what
hargraves yeah whoa what the hell what the heck
yo what the hell is happening beam a signal
or some [__] what's going on here also don't
don't make me do this do you trust me no i don't
what are you doing you gotta be [__] me
you said oh god if they're gonna throw the credits
those would be so mad bro turn back in time
why this happening
i'm going to watch heavy spoilers video
what is happening here so confused
what's wrong
nothing baby no just so happy to be home that's
where you're always meant to be did she die
what is happening she got
everything she wanted or did she
cool i hope the baby's okay
i know it looks strange it's not all big guy
huh oh [__] and that looks like some weird cgi
we're so used to seeing him all bulky
not gonna show sloane i got my arm back
oh no wait where where's sloane oh she was uh
she was right behind me og timeline i don't care
about any resets all right i want my wife back
where is she fine i'm glad you're alive but please
take your hand off me not until you give me an
answer okay screw this oh they lost their powers
okay come on alakazam no tattoos i'm
out [__] oh guys come on we should
stick together and figure this what
are we supposed to do live our lives
you guys are just a separate
man you guys gotta figure this
oh my out it's whoa it's like hard drives
this planet my god hargrave central
we got his wife back was it all
a plan just to get her i think so
wow
lots of wrap ahead around yeah
this is not the way i thought uh this season
would end that's a lot of wtf questions
hi there so here's the deal i'm shooting on my
phone because it's like three in the morning
and uh aaron actually called me
a few hours after we were done
shooting um the final episode reaction
from umbrella cat i was like dude
there was a post credit scene i was like aw crap
did you already watch it he already watched it
and uh he said it's super short but i was
like oh we've gotten this far so might as
well do a quick reaction to it for you guys in my
little editing station here as you can see i've
added new stations right where we film but on the
opposite side but let's see what this is all about
okay we're back on the train
betty
that's it
i don't know what's making
that what what does that mean
i have no idea what's making that is that uh
is this the same bed from the sparrow
academy or is this like another ben
from the uh like this are there gonna
be like two bends is what i'm getting at
just the original bend that got to survive i
don't know what this means for the future of
umbrella academy or for what it's setting up
for season four this the bed that gotta just
live a happy normal life and wasn't tortured and
traumatized to like every bed that we know it
i don't i don't know i'm very clueless
right now as to what to make of this
anyway i'm glad i watched it though but aaron
was telling me he didn't know what to make of
this post credit scene either so regardless it
does not affect our just our very long in-depth
thorough discussion that we have of the episode
talk for a long time so you know stick around if
you're interested in our actual review portions of
it because yeah there's a lot to say but this is
this is a weird post credit scene i have no idea
what it it what it's implying a lot of pondering
a lot of uh yeah i'm just kind of not left with a
feeling of like what the [__] there's a feeling
of like what's going on but it's also just
like a like a calming kind of like like if
the show got canceled after this i'm like i guess
is the end of the show there's just they're human
and they're separated and but obviously there's
going to be another season but yeah i just feel um
i don't even know what i feel i thought
it came from that was a great finale
became pretty haunting yeah in the last like 20
minutes i was like this is some haunting [__]
this is this is uh getting to the
dark part of my soul right now
a hargraved utopia wow evil mastermind
an evil mastermind yeah what was
since that was yeah his plan was he
wanted real estate it's what he wanted
he wanted to be a real estate mogul
he's just all about capitalism
that's all he cared about he really
wanted to win a monopoly to own land
but it all makes sense now with the monocle
you're the monopoly man
this was all good this whole time oh man oh shoot
i didn't know where it was going to go in the end
yeah no and when they're all like [__] harder
are they going to die right now and
they got enough energy to reset the
universe but in hargraves image like but he died
i mean yeah they're very recent like
clear some clear goddamn answers next
i don't know their powers like
luther looks so weird without his
muscle suit on that's just the actor is so
odd how does he know so much how does heart
graves know so much i mean i know he's like an
alien who's like seen everything in anything
but it's it's fascinating we're three seasons in
there's still so much mystery and it's like to the
the world of this character and it seemed like
he had to keep the wife alive yeah well this is
incubated on the moon or some [__] yeah kept
her body on the moon for the event that you'd
bring her back one day why would that matter with
resetting the universe i don't know i have no clue
it doesn't make sense but i'm curiou i feel
like we're gonna get the answers next season
hopefully is there something to do with what
allison constructed with pushing the button
that was her wish fulfillment is that why sloane's
not alive but why would that make it in her in a
hargrave's image that doesn't make sense because
it seems like the deal struck is that hargraves
would get what he wants and allison would get what
she wants yeah reconstructing the entire universe
because rey is a man from the 60s and here he
is now in present day that's what i mean is like
like with whatever buttons he was touching
must have been like my plan allison's plan
right yeah he designed it that way but then
luther gets to come back to life like lizzy
she must have wanted that or they didn't
have powers and all that kind of like a
kind of like a scarlet witch house of em thing you
know in a certain extent of being like mutants or
bad yeah so i want to come back normal so i think
the question was really jarring seeing luther
i was like somebody looks like just normal
he looks very long there's a long limb in
the director just looks like i'm so used to
seeing him like oh buff and [__] but um
i mean yeah it can't be a show without them
without not having powers i mean i feel like
they could do that for a few episodes right
it's crazy because like it it maintained that
play-like quality you know just like a lot of
scenes of just them together debating conversing
arguing up until like the very end other than
like it's got the most action packed with the
oblivion hotel but even though it was
still like contained at the hotel and
i was like oh it is doing the thing i was
kind of saying that i was hoping the show
would do which keep it like very personal and
intimate and then it became like the biggest
in like 10 seconds it was like this is the
biggest i've ever gotten this is massive
yeah they're always i'm up in the ante with this
show um but yeah i mean i quite loved the last
half of this i liked the finale a lot i did i
don't know how people feel about the finale in
general but i i love this finale i i think it
was i think the moment in the garden was a bit
rushed the button it's like luther running
off makes perfect sense to me yeah you gotta
go find this woman yeah yeah he's panicked he
wants to go find her like everyone thinks back
but nothing else matters him like that makes sense
but everyone just like split up in like 30 seconds
like screw family i think you guys probably want
to figure this [__] out together right yeah
like we got a lot of we got a lot
of answers man it makes me wonder if
how they interesting enough i think this
is the only time we've seen where it allows
them to have some sort of time jump because each
yeah yeah each the previous season started from
the moment the last season ended yeah which kind
of frees them up to have a different structure
for whatever season four is gonna be um i have no
idea yeah i don't read the comics for this show so
no i think it's vastly different from the comics
or like the first like couple of um arcs but yeah
this is very different from from what i read
good yeah looks less predictable yeah yeah
everybody can enjoy it even gerard way doesn't
know what the [__] happening and he wrote it
i can imagine a lot of people have issues with
that i imagine allison has been quite a polarizing
portrayal yeah yeah yeah yeah because the show
never quite brings you to a state of understanding
i think i understood but i think the way they
showed her express her grief and frustration
was a little extreme and i don't know if
it was the writing choices or the directing
choices but it's just like in spite
of all her pain i was i don't like you
yeah i don't like the choices that you're making
well it just seems so i mean she seems human
and human i can't deny that it's more of a mixed
bag for me uh when it comes to her like at times
i i really get it at times i'm like your
selfish ways are getting in the [__] way
yeah it really hovers back and forth before me
with her and maybe up even up until this final
decision moment yeah like every like she does feel
like the show tried having a a redeeming quality
by her saving them from death
which is a solid recovery
um but the fact that she did lie her way
to this moment and was very deceptive
because it seemed like hargraves really did want
to honor his deal yeah with her yeah he's like
don't even step on the [__] uh what was it
the sigil the science the stars yeah they're
like don't don't step on it like it seems like he
really was it wasn't it was keen honoring his deal
and and uh and so it's like clearly she
like she seems like she's the one who
lucked out the most in the end yeah i think this
deal and how the it plays out by the very end
kind of makes me really think about hargraves as a
character and who this universe is hard graves is
maybe just all versions of them are the two
versions we've seen in that this man is truly
someone who is about justifying the ends just find
the means because somewhere in his in his spell
of sucking the life force out of him he gave them
new life a new chance to be something without
the burdens of what he's put upon them in a new
reality this is an interesting book end because
it starts off in the season where they're
stranded but they decide to you know find
new settlement together yeah and this starts
off with stranded a new place but they're gonna
just [__] off and go their separate ways yeah
like it's very different um yeah and the other two
i do i i i am kind of bummed about sloane yeah
i'm sure he'll find her you know because there's
what 47 babies something like that did that
still happen here you know i don't know man
it's a lot of questions there's a lot of
questions yeah it kind of makes me ponder
so first season in the second season we go back
in time second season to season three we're in an
alternate timeline so this is seemingly multiverse
we're going into a whole new universe entire new
reality well this this is a reset reset reboot
yeah and i think that's what the seven like i said
like seven you know being very symbolic for like
creation recreation so like creating the universe
yeah and literally it is birthed into his own
image where hargraves land you know yeah he is
he is like god and ruler over this yeah it makes
me wonder well that's because i really started
like sloane that's why yeah especially this
last episode i was like all right we got some
real depth to you now finally you grieving and
revenge and all that like you're a real character
yeah i gave you something to root for for her for
sure i always liked her um but this was like now
i'm like really now i care for you like when the
when it looked like the warrior was gonna stab her
was gonna kill her i was like oh that's sad i was
like kind of bummed at the thought of her dying
yeah i think she's i think she'll be around yeah
a lot happiness a lot i think this is a thick boy
finale and other than that final beat at the
end it didn't feel particularly rushed or too
much to me i i quite enjoyed the chaos of it all
i left me with a couple questions though like what
so we saw in oblivion that five got his arm cut
off right but then the reboot happened but he got
a tattoo so i'm like is that like an offshoot of
the events of what happened in oblivion because he
still got his arm cut off and still got the tattoo
but he's in the the paradox proof panic room
that's a good question i don't know if that
makes sense i don't know if it tracks well i
i mean i think there's a reason they set up
the whole thing about a paradox yeah no i
imagine they'll probably come into season four
because the thing with paradoxes is you go
wait if this didn't happen how did this happen
how did this happen if this didn't happen you know
when they when i forget i forgot what episode
it was like three or episode three or four
when they were explaining what a paradox
is and i think that's part of it is like
i don't know how well they can explain that
but maybe the events of oblivion did happen
but it but but when they went to that
point in the time stream lila and five that
there's still a plane of existence of earth
do you know what i'm getting at like they're still
in existence so the universe wasn't done with
yeah there's well is the do we know that the
time bureau exists within this plane of reality
i don't know i don't [__] remember man
i watched it two years ago just roll with it
it's real fine fine but yeah i i think that um
yeah leaves us with a lot of questions just
with uh i don't know how klaus came back
i have no [__] clue it doesn't make sense but
i liked it i like that he's back there needed to
be some type of physical body yeah cause then all
the times we saw him die he like would return to
that body and it would like fix itself but you
just reanimate yourself out of nothing that's
that's interesting okay we're like ah we wanted
to make a strong choice but don't question how
how we go back on that choice we just just roll
with it i'm it didn't make sense but i was like
okay yeah i like this i like him i like them
together doesn't mean it makes sense we're good
what's logic i don't know but i thought the
visuals were very beautiful yeah except for
the uh the the warrior guy with the holes in
his face it made me think maybe think of like a
like this actual condition where like that's a
thing you have like little worms coming out of
your face yeah that's [__] a real show
it's how it grows it's like there's a lot
of metaphors that are [__] flying all over
my head holes in there cockroaches okay is is
stanley back is stanley still what was the
thing with his ear what was that all about
somebody called mislead into thinking he had some
powers well yeah but that there was never like
a payoff in that mislead i it's a it's a weird
season it is because it starts off with like the
sparrow academy and what is this kugelblitz
and then the last half is very much about
the show seems to function at its best when the
the main focus is stop the world from ending yeah
i wonder if we if we were to go back and watch the
beginning of season three if you can see all of
the through lines for where they end up by the
end of this season because like at some points
it feels like they're just kind of like going
along and like making it up but in other points
like okay there is a point to what is happening
like they like i still don't understand why grace
was so obsessed with the the things like she's a
robot why is she obsessed with yeah they have some
story lines that kind of seem to the idea with the
season usually is like a bunch of different story
lines and you watch the convergence of it and here
was kind of just some some of it was kind of like
it was kind of zigzagging around all
over the place like some of it doesn't
quite make you feel that completion um when you
when you think about it as a whole i really have
two associations with the season the first half
and the last half i didn't hate the first time
the last half to me is very focused and very
concise and clear and powerful and effective
and then the first half they do feel like
two separate halves you know i mean yeah
like it's part of the same story
but execution wise they feel
like not as properly tethered or even like the
grief of harlan kind of feels dropped for victor
yeah i feel like a lot of things happened without
full payoff but like i said like i think i said
at the one of the earlier episodes like things
certain things would kind of happen to further
the plot but without any real sense behind them
and then other things would make sense but would
also do that would make sense for our characters
whether where they were emotionally and that
elevated the plot and i think this season had
a mix of both of those things so i still at the
end of the day it was still a very enjoyable
season of television to watch but i think if
we were comparing it to the other two seasons
of umbrella academy i still think it falls third
for me it does uh it does but it still has some of
the most memorable in a in a very extremely
positive way has some of the most memorable
moments of umbrella academy for me yeah
definitely like one million percent and yeah it
there there are some like character beat
stuff like that i do kind of wish we had
that would have created more
conflict like i i think sloan
you know like once when sloan first
loses those members of the sparrows
she's just she's so upset and then
it's just she's not upset anymore
and and victor and harland i'm like i feel like
that would create some real like it seemed like
victor was just so focused on like i'm mad
at you allison for the way you treat me like
there's a real loss here yeah they never give
her a chance to really process that early like
cece was the love of your life and
that was cece's kid and harlan was
killed and you know like there was a yeah like it
and it didn't in this whole thing with um harlan
kind of like harlan gives up his powers but for
some reason that storyline doesn't feel like
it mattered amounted to much no because
it was such a big part of the first half
yeah cause like you can do one of two things
i it either power victor up enough to to
be something that's that's more um exponential in
in their ability or it could serve as something
that really uh boosts harlan as a character or or
connects those two but i don't i don't think that
if you take harlan out of the show it changes
a lot i mean me it's the catalyst for their rel
the rift between alice and allison
and victor's relationship but
outside of that i don't know if it did a whole lot
i mean it started it started the the cougar blicks
and like the the paradox of that but yeah he
didn't at the end of the day he didn't do much
as a character and i was i was kind of looking
forward to what he was going to do also we don't
know why his name is like it's important but
somehow still feels incomplete yeah yeah like i
said like there's a lot of stuff i enjoyed about
umbrella academy because like at the end of the
day i still enjoy all these characters but there
were some some loose threads and some some things
in there that didn't quite make sense like i still
don't understand what the whole buffalo thing
was it just like a physical representation to show
that this was the other half of a dimension or
the other side of a a portal door was there more
significance to that sure yeah these were a lot of
questions but i can say that at the end of the day
i did enjoy watching this i had a really fun time
doing this with you and i think that i like i'm
gonna continue to watch the show yeah and i love
lila a lot on this you know like lilo was such
a in the previous mischievous villain and then
here i i quickly bought her as one of the main
protagonists yeah like not a villain at all like
like no you're you're one of the good ones yeah
did did ben work for you by the end of the season
he's all right i didn't love ben but yeah but i
didn't mind ben by the in the last few episodes
in the last few i didn't mind him yeah i went
from like hating him to like tolerating him
yeah to being like he's fine yeah and they
also never really go into the the whole
jennifer thing with him sure i was hoping they
would because you see all the pictures and art
they kind of allude to it without really diving in
deep which i'm like yeah yeah yeah there's a lot
of there's a lot of stuff that they just do for
the sake of doing without following through i mean
there's a lot to appreciate though i mean i think
i do i think the finale i love the setting of
i feel like there's still more to explore yet
i still really like the execution of having
this sort of ominous horror tone like it was
suspenseful it was it was really like when they
started walking through you know like different
when the hotels kind of turning in on them yeah it
was cool yeah like that was that was intense that
was that was really suspenseful it was pretty cool
and uh i really like yeah i really like
that a lot and and uh yeah that was fine
klaus you do see how his powers do come like
he was able to just kind of like summon luther
yeah so the button kind of that's what i mean
there's a lot happening there because like
luther's dead he's in the afterlife they get back
there luther gets to save the day say goodbye to
sloane and it's a ghost and oh it's sad and
then and and and then um and then he's back
he's back it's like weird hey come here yeah
yeah um like i guess in some ways some things
could have used a bit more breathing room but
in the immediacy of the moment it wasn't feeling
rushed to me and kind of reflecting i'm like yeah
maybe it could have been a little longer to
help let some things kind of pace out a little
bit better um but i i do think that overall this
was still like it still gets me excited to come
i still i'm still excited for season four and
i still want to uncover what's gonna happen in
season four i want to see the completion of the
story yeah i would hate for it to end here no
yeah yeah i would hate for like it could end here
i would think that would suck though if it ended
here i'm like no we gotta see we gotta see what
happens i think that'd be a terrible final scene
oh okay i guess it was just a really really downer
note yeah like whatever wins and they all separate
yeah there is something really odd about the
way that final moments played out to me but
i'm gonna use a little bit they didn't ever quite
have that scene like there tends to be like like
a cool like a great sequence that just stands out
you know what i also realized there was never like
they're the umbrella academy but there's never
like that team moment you know like how they
had in season two i still think season
two is the strongest season of the show
definitely i i agree i i know a couple people
who prefer season one overall um but no season
two for me is still my personal favorite i
would say the strongest i would have liked to
to watch them work together as like he said we
need the seven or seven of them to do this and
granted they were they all seven for standing on
the pieces so the machine would work but i would
like to see seven of them or all of them work
with their powers together all avengers style or
justice league style you know to try to take down
whatever these threats were but i guess at the end
of the day it's it's not really a superhero show
in spite of the fact that the premise started with
these siblings that were formed to originally be
a superhero team yeah yeah i mean i think what
makes this show charming is oddities it's gonzo
nature it's it's like when it just leans into its
weirdness and absurdity yeah you know
like it's not it's not the weirdest season
there's something that's kind of like unsettling
in the last like there's something that's kind
of like unsettling it's more melancholic what
i respect about this show a lot is i can say
each season feels very different 100 and i think
that's a really cool thing to say is they they all
feel different yeah you know kudos to them or not
like the first one felt a little bit more gothic
yeah gothic kind of grounded you know like yeah
before they really like upped their budget you
know they had to like really rely on all the
character drama in the first season and then
the second one was like that 60s backdrop and uh
it got really weird with it more fun and exciting
and this had more of uh an acceptance of
death you know dealing with that and but
it yeah the tone flair didn't start really
clicking for me until the last half yeah but
there's a yeah there's a lot about the mood this
is like the dark knight rises out of the trilogy
movie yeah yeah you know where i'm like there's a
lot visually and tonally that i really love about
this one and there's some really exciting stuff
but i definitely feel like it's the the third one
yeah yeah i want a more pogo man i liked biker
pogo which we got to see more of his life and
more of his involvement with the family and
what his relationship was with the sparrows
yeah this is not the most fulfilling season i
would say i keep going back to things that are
just adjectives of feeling a little incomplete
in some arenas yeah i like like i said i i know
a lot about i was like man dude [__] this
the last half you should have gone to like
this [__] a little faster mm-hmm i don't
i didn't feel like we needed to get to take
that long to get to that especially when they're
like yeah sparrows don't really [__] matter i
yeah and um when when the when they set you up for
that and you're just like a screw it um so that's
why i said i feel like you didn't really have
a little clear vision it's a little disjointed
in that regard and i feel like the last half is so
much better and so good but because they only have
a certain number of episodes to do you know it's
like if they had just done the plot line that the
episode five and more and on introduces or episode
six and on truly introduces if that was the like
more of the focus and jumping point instead of
any of this like sparrow academy [__] and like
you know what it felt like to me it
felt like at the end of season two
they wrote themselves into a hole and it took them
yeah they were like six episodes to figure out how
the [__] they were getting themselves
we don't really want to do this sparrow
we're gonna change ben's hair we're not gonna make
the sparrows matter all that much we're gonna make
some full characters but uh we just want to get
to this point and by any means necessary we're
gonna get there yeah they felt very disposable
they literally were like harlan killed two of
them like nothing i don't remember how raven
lady died i just felt like google blitz things
google blitz you got blitz and then so did
christopher yeah right well there's a lot to
enjoy about the season but there's a lot that kind
of annoyed me and aggravated me as well but like
i don't know it's like it it needs to like somehow
thematically play in or emotional wise play in
yeah and then you know what also something is
like i said they would do things without actually
um making them fully matter like the whole
conversation about that five had with
with uh victor about doing if you do things
alone like you become the villain and like if
you do that [__] again i'll kill you myself
now like that never really came back into play
yeah that's what i mean is is they set up a lot of
really that's what i mean is like if the last half
was the first five episodes essentially and then
they had five more to expand like you get to the
apocalypse ending at the very end of that
different alternate timeline 10 that i'm
talking about in my own head cannon then then they
they really could have had like a pretty perfect
season three that feels like really doom and gloom
and melancholic and because i really loved like i
i loved at least three of these episodes there was
at least three episodes i truly loved in here and
like seven eight and nine i thought were like i
love them and 10's a pretty damn great finale it's
just because it's a finale it gets you to kind
of look at the whole picture and uh i thought it
was good i thought i thought the family was good i
don't think i loved it as much as you but i liked
it a lot yeah i was surprised by how much i liked
it i thought they were going to drop the ball
i think six seven and eight were my favorites six
seven and eights were the ones that i absolutely
loved six again what happened six is when i
was like that was really good and then 789 and
i was like these are awesome i started yeah you
started to flip around in six i think six is when
harlan got killed uh that's five no it's six no
was it six pretty sure there was six i only got
at the very end of five i know six is when lila
and diego first go into the oblivion i don't
remember how it ends but six is when i really
felt like this is a turning point i remember
feeling like this is a turning point but seven
was when i was like wow that was great yeah and
eight was like oh my god they did it again and i
really i really liked episode nine a lot i thought
episode 9 was pretty awesome it got me jazzed
about the finale yeah episode 9 was really good
yeah i really liked the the the wedding episode i
think that was uh the most heartfelt for me i was
eight yeah and that's what i mean like those tones
they mastered here that seven and eight like that
real like they never really became as fun as like
season two but in terms of like going into this
like the this this feeling of death
and appreciating just your loved ones
and the ones you live with yeah so that's
why i mean like the ending kind of like
undercuts a lot of that for me here i just like
[__] got by i'm like it would have been more
powerful if there was some type of emotion to
them separating if they had time to just like
have like luther could go off but it's like what
do we do and they instead of just being like uh
in some ways it's very umbrella academy but
i feel like for a finale it it i i would have
personally preferred a bit of an emotional
button like they still could have separated
but i would have liked it more if there was some
type of emotional undercurrent to them going their
separate ways yeah i'll say in some ways for me
emotionally this season season three of umbrella
academy is like the emotional equivalent
of like stranger things season two for me
so i think the only thing i think series
of things three is my least favorite really
i really enjoyed season three the the
action like the uh the blockbuster season
i dug it i ran whenever we watched them i was like
threes a week that's a pretty four is killing it
four's killing there's a reason
four feels nothing like three
but hey maybe umbrella academy had that same
luck with the with a killer season four you know
a focus season four they're never gonna give them
that much money you know what i think if i'm happy
i didn't i really enjoyed the journey of how we
got here i wasn't over head over heels in love
with it like it was season two but i think where
we end the season gives us a lot of potential
for them to really shine and really do
something creative and new going forward because
they haven't they haven't written themselves
into a immediate action kind of cliffhanger
yeah they can do a time job if they
want to to help figure things out
and and us find these characters in these new
places um until something else ultimately has
to bring them back together yeah i think season
one and two did a great job but like what are
our starting points for our characters in the
first and second episode and then what is the
completion by the end yeah i think and here i'm
like oh that first five feels very different
and their and their arcs don't feel that
clear as a unit or as individuals yeah and
weirdly enough in some ways if they play it right
this almost is like um like a reprisal or like uh
some because at the end of the beginning how the
series starts with everybody separated you know
so where we end this third season is everybody
disperses again right so the fourth season gives
them the opportunity for them to all be in those
places what are their lives for them some sort of
event to have to bring them back together again
right what is the audience score on this season
oh yeah i don't want too many people that watched
it either i have like one it's not getting as many
i don't think it's getting as many views as
the previous season i wonder why that is um
i'm going to check the audience score here because
for stranger things was gone longer than the
umbrella academy was and then they're firing all
cylinders as far as views and audience ratings
go it's [__] stranger things like completely
different beasts the flagship show of netflix i
mean the reviews are really high for
season three this is 90 wow that's
very high is it higher than season 102 i mean
season two is 91 percent season two is great
season two has ah like 40 more reviews so that's
pretty good season one is the lowest of the critic
reviews fascinating the audience scores pretty low
it's 62 for this season yeah huh um yeah i mean
don't know it doesn't matter
either way i enjoyed it
yeah this is kind of fascinating
now 62 it was pretty low
it's like right on the edge of passing
god damn um but i haven't dived in to see the
opinions but that is pretty low because i think
season two is like 89 or something um it's a
great season that's great this is the best one uh
yeah guys thank you for being here thanks aaron
for joining me thank you for having me it's been
a pleasure interesting enough to leave on and
hey uh stick around for whatever more we decide
to cover appreciate y'all much love reject
nation glad we gotta complete this journey
you